yes and it's going to be even windier as
we get through the day and tonight so it
is going to be a dusty again for our
thursday beautiful shot though as we
look across the city this morning
the good news is our tall buildings
along the las vegas strip don't rock in
the wind when the winds are up to 25 30
miles an hour and we're not really
expecting anything too rough although
40 maybe 45 and we've already seen 45 in
the mountains that just does enough to
really spread dust and spread all the
pollen around but it could be strong
enough to you know put trash out on the
roads and that could get in your way
today and also even pull down some very
lightweight tree limbs you know the
winds have been off and on for a while
now so there could be stuff just getting
ready to fall
because it's been rocked by the winds
for so long through the spring air
quality as far as dust moderate to even
unhealthy levels at times especially for
sensitive groups if you have respiratory
illnesses if you're suffering from
allergies being in the wind today is not
going to make you feel good at all i'd
stay indoors if you can i know not all
of us can but if you can that would be
good limit your time outdoors lots of
60s this morning red rocks getting the
wind trump's getting the breezes just
about everybody boulder city getting the
wind 70 in mesquite 64 in boulder city
68 in laughlin up the road ely's got
some strong winds even death valley has
had gusts over 40 miles an hour early
this morning sitting at 75 degrees reno
getting in a little rain and snow right
now with strong winds that snow is
pushing across the california state line
there and we're looking at this cold
front which will affect all of us in
fact it will make it all the way down
through southern nevada by tomorrow and
that's going to drop the temperatures
today wind advisories look at the sierra
winter storm warnings and fire weather
warnings too for southern nevada into
arizona boy that fire that's northeast
of flagstaff it's called the tunnel fire
it has exploded to 20 000 acres now and
so many people hundreds of people have
been evacuated fortunately no injuries
but they are looking at the threat to
some historical and cultural
markers and
some places there that could be
threatened by this fire but there's been
already at least a couple of dozen
structures that have been destroyed so
boy people are just trying to get out of
the way there all right so let's get
over to those uh warning maps we've got
wind advisories that now include all of
southern nevada
including las vegas and areas around
northern arizona southeast california
and fire weather warnings dry conditions
strong gusty winds
great conditions for a fire getting out
of control but that's not good news for
us 83 degrees for the high today sliding
to 70 tomorrow some neighborhoods not
out of the 60s for friday it's going to
be cool get some light jackets out and
maybe even a thunderstorm with a chance
of some showers for the valley snow
possible in the mountains and then a
beautiful weekend breezy at times but
not consistent next week it gets hot
again we're looking at 90. so we'll be
flipping on the air conditioner